salut tout le monde connaît léonard de
vinci par sa joconde et son mystérieux
petit sourire et aussi ses fameux sur
tille qui ont disparu avec le temps mais
en plus de la peinture léonard avait
plein d'activités à côté notamment
celles d'ingénieurs alors aujourd'hui on
va parler de ses six inventions les plus
folles dont certaines existent
aujourd'hui par exemple le char d'assaut
le parachute mais ce harnais son âme a
dit qu'il avait pensé à tout non plus la
tesla un peu incroyable mais ça c'est
pas vrai par exemple est beaucoup
d'inventions sont sortis de son
imagination et ont parfois mis quatre
siècles avant d'être réalisé aujourd'hui
on s'en sert c'est un peu fou loïc
fabrique-moi un générique de g
[Musique]
première invention le char d'assaut
avant d'être peintre à léonard de vinci
est avant tout un ingénieur qui
travaille pour les plus puissants de son
époque et vers les années 1500 il se
rend chez le duc de milan qui
responsable à cette époque de la défense
de milan contre les français et lui
présente un dessin parce qu'il est comme
ça lui on arrive fait des petits dessins
un dessin d'une plate forme ronde sur
lesquels sont placés des canons tout
autour et au dessus il ajout d'une
carapace en forme de cône renforcée par
des plaques de métal qui permet de
dévier les projectiles ennemis lancé par
des canaux ou des catapultes le char
toujours sur le dessin est déplacé par
huit tonnes qui actionne des manivelles
à l'intérieur pour faire rouler le tout
la machine peut même se déplacer à 360
degrés la cerise sur le gâteau c'est la
petite tourelle qui a ajouté léonard de
vinci au sommet pour permettre un soldat
de coordonner le tout canon et pilotage
en même temps et on imagine que léonard
s'inspirait des tours de combat des
grecs les et l'épaule ou encore des
tours mobile des romans léonard a donc
gagné sa vie en réalisant des projets
militaires principalement il inventera
d'ailleurs d'autres armes comme la
catapulte à percussion ou encore
l'ancêtre de la mitrailleuse c'est fou
et le premier char d'assaut opérationnel
lui verra le jour en 1916 un peu
longtemps après sur le champ de bataille
de la première guerre mondiale soit
quatre cents ans après l'idée de losne 2
le chevalier mécanique
quelques années plus tôt léonard était
invité à des festivités à milan par la
même personne ludovic sforza et quand
leonard il a invité quelque part il est
poli il vient pas les mavs il fait tout
petit dessin là ils ramènent pas un
dessin il ramène avec lui un automate
qui a la taille d'un humain camouflé
sous un chevalier en armure
c'est un peu fou d'automates et en bois
en cuir un en métal il peut se tenir
debout s'asseoir un peu même agité les
bras et même ouvrir et fermer sa
mâchoire sa bouche mais carrément des
sons avec un petit mécanisme à
percussion qui est placé en haut du
torse et le tout fonctionne avec un
juste un système de câbles des poulies
des engrenages sont juste très
ingénieusement répartis à l'intérieur de
l'automate léonard a construit son
automate en s'inspirant de ses propres
recherches qu'il avait fait sur l'homme
de vitruve vous avez sans doute déjà vu
le célèbre dessin de de vinci
ça représente un homme aux proportions
idéales il y en a un qui est l'album
fonds et
un deuxième dans le fond et l'homme de
vitruve ça devait permettre d'aider à la
construction d' architecturaux dimension
qui aurait été elle aussi idéale si on
partait du principe que les dimensions
de l'homme était idéal vous m'avez
compris plusieurs exemplaires
fonctionnelle du chevalier ont été
reconstitués entre 96 et 2007
après les notes retrouvées dans le codex
atlanticus qui est conservé à la
bibliothèque ambrosienne 2000 ans est
l'un des recueils de dessins et de notes
laissées par léonard de vinci il répond
mille couverts en 1515 à la cour de
françois 1er avec un lion mécanique
cette fois ci c'est vraiment le mec il
arrive quelques pavés a été pour dîner
j'ai ramené à lyon mécanique qui fait
croire 3 l'automobile
alors ok on va pas parler de la tesla
mais déjà au moyen-âge et pendant la
renaissance des ingénieurs avaient créé
des moyens de faire avancer de manière
mécanique des charrettes sans l'aide
d'animaux là c'est un peu la tesla de
l'époque mais c'est léonard de vinci qui
en 1478 à l'âge de 24 ans avec des
jeunes qui a créé un prototype plus
moderne avec un design bien plus sympa
la mécanique de son prototype de
tricycle à ressort est basé sur le
principe de l'horlogerie il s'agit d'une
structure en bois et en métal dont
l'énergie élastique accumulés dans les
arbalètes entraîne le mouvement des
engrenages relié aux roues et quand est
ce que les renards a présenté ce petit
bijou d'après vous à une fa est
évidemment celle donnée dans les grand
duché de toscane que je disais qu'il
arrivait jamais les mains vides
il en existe une maquette fonctionnel
d'ailleurs depuis 2004 bon alors léonard
n'avait pas encore pensé à la ceinture
de sécurité ni au gps mais vous allez
voir juste après avec le parachute que
la sécurité s'était peut-être pas sa
priorité priorité aux départs en 1960 un
autre dessin intéressant a été découvert
entre deux pages coller du codex
atlanticus ring ça je trouve ça fou
quand on a un truc tu es tout connaît
courte ou le codex on l'a étudié tout un
moment des faits monsieur collet saint
michel à une autre invention et ce
dessin c'est celui d'une machine qui
ressemble beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup à
ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui sous le nom
de bicyclette le document est daté de
1493 mais certaines personnes pensent
que le dessin serait un fou à bicyclette
c'est d'ailleurs peut-être comme ça que
votre facteur va vous livrer votre
numéro de juillet-août de mon magazine
curieuse c'est en pleine transition 62
cloches de curiosité de cerveau de
sciences d'art et tout ce qui peut
stimuler vos neurones vous connaissez et
votre facteur va bulli
ray avec dix pages en plus parce que oui
curieuse fait maintenant 62 pages c'est
sur cette ferme c'est définitif même
après l'été et c'est un peu fou quand on
se souvient qu'il ya un tout petit peu
plus d'un an je lançais le premier
numéro du magazine et que ça faisait 42
pages en et passe à 52 maintenant 62
c'est toujours le même prix 29 euros 90
par an pour un abonnement à toute
l'année chez vous frais de port inclus
et dans ce prochain curieuse vous allez
trouver non pas un mais bien deux
articles qui sont consacrés à léonard de
vinci pour tout connaître sur le maître
florentin vous avez le lien dans la
description pour découvrir curieuse elle
est résumée robes sont déjà sortis pour
info si vous voulez bien recevoir à
partir du numéro du mois prochain il
faut vous inscrire avant le 17
quand on voit là si vous inscrivez le 17
juin vous recevez à partir de juillet
passons maintenant aux 4
le parachute entre 1480 1502 léonard se
creuse la tête et réfléchit à la
réalisation de l'un des plus grands
fantasmes de l'humanité volée il imagine
une toile pyramidale de 12 brasse de
large par 12 brasse 2e ou le converti
sept mètres de large sur sept mètres de
haut le tout maintenu par un cadre carré
en bois à l'intérieur
bon alors on n'est pas encore sûr
jean-jacques y parfaire son petit saut
du dimanche parce que ça demande un
petit peu de logistique pour mac le
machin en place mais leona est persuadé
qu'avec son dispositif n'importe qui
dans l'humanité peut sauter sans risque
à partir de n'importe quel auteur sans
risque puisque petit détail d'après les
dessins de léonard la personne qui
sautait devait se tenir à l'ensemble par
les mains y avait pas de harnais il n'y
avait pas de trucs comme ça
en gros c'est à peu près ça tu vois sauf
que là c'est pas attacher un casque sur
la tête mais c'est le gars qui tient par
ses mains mais voilà c'est à peu près
idée est ce que ça vole montreuil
d'ailleurs
pâton malgré sa en 2008 le parachutiste
suisse olivier gui tite et pas ceux de
650 mètres avec une réplique vraiment du
parachute de bernard bon ils ont quand
même enlevé le cadre en bois parce qu'il
faut pas déconner non plus ils ont
rajouté un harnais relié par des cordes
au parachute pas il faut pas déconner
non plus comme un vrai parachute en fait
un petit joueur
bon ça s'explique comme pour beaucoup de
ses inventions léonard de vinci était
tributaire des matériaux de son époque
là n'est pas inventer des trucs
n'existait pas non plus et il y avait
peu de chances pour que son parachute et
vu le jour de son vivant au final en 5
le scaf ans beaucoup d' inventions de
léonard de vinci sont des améliorations
d'idées qui avait déjà le vent en poupe
à son époque déjà au moyen-âge les
hommes
il s'intéressait à voler mais aussi un
autre rêve celui de nager sous l'eau de
respirer sous l'eau plus ou moins
profondément sans se soucier du risque
principal
tu connais la noyade bien qu'il n'y ait
pas vraiment de dessins de l'ensemble on
sait que léonard de vinci à travailler
sur une combinaison de plongée équipé
d'un masque auquel serait relié des
tuyaux fabriqués avec du bambou est
renforcée par les anneaux en acier
tuyaux qui eux seraient fixées à une
cloche d'air maintenu à la surface par
un flotteur en liège plutôt malin en
vrai ça fonctionne l'ensemble aurait pu
permettre aux armées de détruire les
vaisseaux ennemis en passant sous loue
depuis les profondeurs peu comme dans
pirates des caraîbes dans le premier
camp yven attaque et actes actes sous
l'eau par contre fallait mieux pas être
vegan pour reporter le scaphandre dans
l'ensemble c'était cuir de porc
uniquement et imperméabilisées avec de
l'huile de poisson pour qu'ils soient
hydrophobe d'un appétit et puis courage
pour l'odeur petit détail et pas des
moindres son système ne permet pas de
plonger au delà de quelques mètres à
peine en raison de la pression de l'eau
et le terme de scaphandres est apparue
d'ailleurs lui que au xviiie siècle dans
les années 1700 on peut donc se demander
comment léonard avait après son
invention peut-être combinaison à poux
voilà dites moi dans les commentaires
quand comment vous pensez vraiment qu'il
aurait appelé ça tu te dis bon alors
j'ai inventé mon truc avec la peau des
cochons vous inquiétez pas on a pressé
des tonnes de poisson pour faire de
l'huile et c'est bien un imperméable
on appelle ça comment quand même la
tenue à blood hbo non je ne sais pas je
le dirai vos commentaires 6 les écuries
automatise beaucoup plus intéressant que
ce qu'il n'y paraît quand un personnage
dont vous avez jamais entendu parler
dans cette vidéo
ludovic soir à coire est toujours veut
rénover ses écuries il appelle
ainsi pour travailler là-dessus
l'inventeur réfléchit alors un véritable
palais pour chevaux l'idée c'était de
rendre tout automatique
toute la structure de manière à
faciliter le travail très très long fait
habituellement par les hommes dans un
carnet intitulé l'écurie propres est
revendeur seul écureuil propres de
demain s'imagine un bâtiment de 60
mètres de longueur sur 15 mètres de
large dans lequel seraient hébergés pas
moins de 128 chevaux répartis sur quatre
ans j'ai de 30 de boxe premier truc
sympa l'évacuation du purin se fait via
des rigoles et des réseaux souterrains
donc il ya plus besoin de se mettre les
mains dans le caca deuxième invention
appréciable le fonds est conservé à
l'étagé et tombe par l'intérieur des
murs jusqu'à des soupiraux situé au
dessus des mangeoires le troisième truc
qui est pas mal c'est pour les
abreuvoirs l'idée c'était de les ériger
à l'aide d'un système de pompe à eau
directement reliée à la rivière qui a
plus besoin de transporter la flotte
deux siècles plus tard au xviie siècle
les écuries du domaine de chaumont la
guiche c'est en saône et loire sont
construites selon les plans de léonard
de vinci est aujourd'hui alors elles
sont plus entièrement fonctionnel mais
le bâtiment existe toujours mais ils ont
vraiment tout repris le système à la
base les écuries de la ville
arco nati dans la région de milan
pourraient également avoir été
construite selon le même modèle donc il
a pas planché pour rien léonard de vinci
à imaginer des dizaines de machins et de
machines différentes lavisse aériennes
par exemple que vous avez derrière
serait ni plus ni moins que l'origine de
l'hélicoptère d'ailleurs si vous
regardez l'abyssale reagan de los nar et
une gêne qui le petit hélico c'est la
nasa qui a volé sur mars il ya quelques
semaines il ya un petit air de famille
quand même
bref je vous laisserai également
parcourir le prochain numéro de
curieuses qui sort en juillet pour
apprendre bien plus sur cet homme qui
est vraiment passionnant il ya les deux
dossiers qui à l'intérieur
moi je m'appelle toujours fabien olicard
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à cette
chaîne
ça c'est gratuit activer la cloche comme
ça vous ratez pas la prochaine vidéo
et puis là qu'est la vidéo si elle vous
a plu là je vous mets une vidéo sur
sursis ce quelque chose c'est sur six
autres choses et je vous mets mes
préférés peu importe les dates de sortie
j'espère juste que le prochain numéro
curieuse va vous plaire toujours autant
que les précédents merci de votre
confiance prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt
on n'avait pas entendu aujourd'hui parce
que